This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina [inaudible],
our buddies coming over.
Which buddy airy the mayor of New
York titties coming over here.
I know. I can't wait to see
him and his little curls.
Well that'd be here very shortly. We've
been friends in the area for a long time.
He's been our guy long time.
Arie Shaffer now he's all east coast area.
East Coast airy
and a strange ranger.
I can't wait to hear what he's been up to.
Definitely got a weird something
going on. What's going on? Well,
let's start this show. Let's get
into, sure, sure, sure. Jean shirt.
Play with our genes,
our genes. These chicks.
I'll do anything for a buck.
Horny.
Bored housewives are waiting
and you watch these bitches.
Big Black Cocks.
How do they do it?
Yeah,
try it out. You made such a dad face
like you are like a dad playing a guitar.
I was jamming out with because Lou
reed. Hey Lou reed. I don't hate him,
but um,
I love the velvet underground.
I likely read and were affected
when he died. I was, cause I,
I like the velvet underground more than
I liked his independent stuff. Yeah.
But when he died you were
very disrespectful. Oh,
you were so disrespectful.
You were like, fuck Lou Reed.
I don't know what put him,
I don't give a show Ballou poker
room. A bus driver from the Bronx. Now
you are pretty much like that.
You're like, fuck that guy.
I don't like his fuck his shit.
No, I wasn't wearing, you're very,
I don't like his fucking Shit fucking
shit. But you were, you're just very like,
ah, I don't care. That sounds more like
me, Lou Reed, whatever. I don't care.
That sounds like, I think because
you don't like good things.
Like you don't like good music.
Right. The way I like good stuff
so far,
so far argument.
We were in the car and there's like two
songs in your whole iTunes library that
I really like and the rest I'm like,
is this real or do they just pull one
gifted me tones.
But you listen to like mall music,
like the shit they play an h and m,
that's the shit that's in your
iTunes like Rihanna or fucking like,
I know a lot of people like, and I
don't, I'm, I'm ashamed to say I don't,
I couldn't name tell me the story
again of me that waking up last year,
the worst. You're such an
asshole. You're the worst.
So our child, our infant was
crying at two 30 in the morning.
First child was crying it one
hour before you and I being super,
super preggers at we, we sleep upstairs,
the baby's downstairs. So I was like,
I don't want to get up, go
downstairs. It's hard for me
to lift him at this point.
So woke you up on the first cry in
a fucking deep sleep on that one.
You always in a deep sleep. Okay.
So, oh no, I'll throw up. And um,
so the second crying fit of
crying comes and I sleep light.
I'm immediately awake.
The dogs are up there like who's crying?
The whole house is up except for you.
You're in a deep snore
and I can't reach over to
touch you because I have
that pregnancy pill that I'm
in Cayston. I can't like touch you
too far from me. And so I'm like Tom,
Tom, Tom and I keep getting
louder and I go, Tom Segura,
Tom Cigar, Tom Cigarette.
I'm like screaming.
The dogs are like jumping up and down,
like freaked out and you're
just sawing away. I'm like,
this is on fucking bully of
all. I didn't hear a thing. No,
because you're in such a coma.
And thankfully he stopped crying.
He put himself back to sleep.
But I was like, this is
the thing is you get a little
adrenaline when you first jump.
Like when I went down at one 30 you have
a little adrenaline to get up out of
sleep and go down to,
you know,
to pick up your kid. Right? So I went
and I went down there. I was like, Ooh.
And I remember when I sat in the
chair with him, I was like, Oh shit,
like I'm half asleep right
now. And he went, he,
he chilled back down pretty easily.
But when I got back to bed,
man,
that really,
you're so ridiculous.
I,
I sang it just as easy as
I have no recollection of
this obviously. No, I know.
And I was like,
I can't believe he's sleeping straight.
You were ripping through it.
I love it.
You said my full name course.
Thompson Thompson hoping that maybe
you thought I was referring to.
I had indifferent Tom in the room
and you were like, that can't be me.
That's not my thought with me here.
It so fucking crazy dude.
How you deep you are.
You're such a deep sleeper.
But it's good cause I get up every
hour to p practically and I'm like, Oh,
I'm just waking this
poor guy up all night.
Don't remember fully disrespecting this
guy. When he died, he did not like him.
How would, I don't even know
Yana, any super fans. I think
I,
I know I have a somewhat of recollection.
I think what happened to be fair
is that when he died and was like,
what's he known for? I was
like, oh, I don't care for
that. Like, whatever he did,
I don't care for.
So,
oh,
it doesn't on the wild
side. And I don't look at
it, I'm saying I, I'm like,
I don't care for it. It doesn't affect
me. No. And therefore his death is like,
you know, I'm not happy he's dead, but
I'm just saying like, you know, no,
you were a little hostile. It was
that. Yeah, it was a day for you.
It was an off day. I think maybe
you were taking it out on Lou Reed.
Really Yanas out there listening.
Uh,
if y'all could reference said episode
and question super fans out there,
we could dig up that audio blue band
and we could replay your reaction to Lou
Reed's dad. I don't know how this
came to us, but this is from, oh,
you're just changing the subject just
so that this is a Lou Reed. Oh, oh,
I'm sorry. I don't know how
this, this video came to us,
but this is a special feature from the
thinking triple x DVD featuring Lou Reed,
very reading various taglines
from tricolor triple x
movies and advertisements.
Right. Cool. Why this is in our inbox,
but I like it. Yeah, you like it.
There's no reason for me to read the
title of the piece. I love the title.
Welcome Lou. Sure, sure. Welcome.
Little pause. Yeah. Really welcome.
Low by Lou Reed. Yeah.
Welcome Lou by Lew. Hey Lew.
These chicks,
I'll do anything for a buck horny.
Bored housewives are waiting from you.
Watch these bitches be Ainley destroyed.
Big Black Cocks.
How do they do it in the same
penetration is a fucking baseball bat.
No bullshit.
These horny women will do anything.
Why be alone?
Japanese hardcore anime and Ken Tie Art
Nasty and the 25,000 x x x by today's
best Asian artists.
These women will moan for you the flesh
pussy tighter and better than the real
thing and they won't Tom back.
It's
real nice when they do the voiceover
with a toothpick in his guy was just
thinking that that was very distracting.
I mean, you know, you know what, honestly,
not enunciating the way you should
be with to in your mouth. No.
You know who hates toothpick users?
Your dad hates them. Yeah. Like,
since I was a little kid would point out,
look at this fucking asshole with his
fucking tooth. Picky thinks is cool.
And he just had the such disdain
for this Kinda toothpick thing.
Like where it's hanging. Yeah.
Yeah. Hanging out of your mouth.
He said you look so stupid to picking
the food out of his mouth to the fucking
toothpick. Why? Why there to
stay pluralize it toothpicks.
Why do you think you're still upset?
I don't know.
He must've had some early childhood
experience with toothpicks that stuck with
it. Excuse me. That's pregnant
vomiting and my own mouth. Um,
I don't know. He, he just felt it
was very American and very crass.
You think I'm not a big tooth pick
user or, you know, I mean, I, I will,
if I'm leaving a place as I'm leaving,
if I feel like I need it and they have
them, I'll do that for that moment.
You know, like if you don't
know, I feel something here,
but I'm not always getting toothpicks.
I feel like they don't really
do adult job around with them.
Like this fucking jackass.
Oh, there's a disdain, right?
You go there it goes. Yeah.
I don't think they do much.
I feel like they just pushed the
food further in between your teeth.
Level of disrespect for the
people that asked me to come in.
I'm gonna do a voice over with it.
Toothpick in my mouth. I agree.
Well he's Lou Reed, man. I know, but why
don't you start chewing gum? I'd be like,
I'm going to do the fucking
voiceover chewing gum. Quiet. Hey,
do you guys like that? It's
part of the show. She's,
they got their summer dog hair cuts
today. Yeah, that's on my Instagram.
If you want to see it's weeks old by
now. Oh, well that's true. But uh,
they look so stupid.
We cut their hair short.
I'm trying to get ahead of
the game cause uh, she has,
Christina has this tumor in
her belly and we got gotta.
We got to take a big shit.
Toki used to have about of,
I didn't know I was pregnant. Yeah, that
show we were watching. Well, we just saw,
I didn't know I was pregnant
again. This is a, it's called,
I still didn't know I was pregnant. I
still don't know. Then I was like, no way.
Not Again,
but didn't you have the gym buddy that
fucking already went through this? Yeah,
the same dumb,
dumb and now twice as dumb.
Dumb doesn't know whether you're a joke
was like a how to tig shit and then when
I took shit it was a baby.
It's a highway or something like that.
I forget the word. Oh God. Take a shit.
Then when I went to shit,
it wasn't a, it was a baby.
Baby took Kim on not
oh order now mister j Watson Akron rights.
I increased the length of my
penis by three inches in one week,
girth by two inches.
My wife is delighted and saw my,
with your end valuable product.
Big fucking African brothers.
Put it to the white bitch.
And how is what these slots swan to
facial cumshots on our famous come shake.
Yes, that's right. I want it.
It does sound like slam poetry when
he reads these descriptions now.
Yeah. Looks like if I took the
tooth pick out he did. Yeah.
That's interesting. He made a good
choice there. Real Nice. Real Nice.
You fucking Korean already can, by
the way. I can already tell you that.
I'll get these butthurt emails now.
Three was my favorite.
She's alleging I like to, I, Hey, you
disrespect. I liked, we read a lot.
I thought it was very sad when he
died. Yeah, I didn't care. Wow.
I can't wait until Skinner dies.
And you start crying rivers. Who?
Leonard Skinner. I cry about that. Well,
remember we were pulling up and you
were like, you had, first of all,
I've never heard a full Leonard
Skinner and song in my life. Yeah.
You played it for me. What did you play?
Free Bird, right? I know the title. No,
this was a Saturday night. Uh,
okay. Yeah. Saturday night.
No, no. You're like, I don't,
you know, you stupid bitch. No,
you've never fucking listened to
scanner. Now a shuffle. It's not,
you're acting like you're
grabbing the valley.
We don't listen to Leonard Skinner
in the San Fernando Valley. Okay.
God,
we more class than that.
It's a, here's a sonic Saturday night
special. Okay. I bought that song. Uh,
after hanging out with Joey
Diaz or does he like, yeah,
he played it for me and I bought it. I
liked the song. I like the way it opened.
Can I hate that shit?
That shit is like, yeah,
but you think that I would
be emotionally affected.
They have some like that favor.
You're always playing.
Scanning even know the name of
the song you play WWE, we parked,
we were parked in the driveway. I remember
a couple of days ago. And you're like,
this is Leonard. I know,
I know what you're saying,
but you're saying that I would be
affected. Yeah, he'd probably cry.
Cause I remember,
you know,
every time I hear one of your garbage
music's like that in your iTunes.
Really,
really disrespectful with this shit.
I imagine you in college in
South Carolina, North Carolina,
same thing and the two,
and you,
you and your friends are sitting in lawn
chairs and you're drinking your beers
and there's like a barbecue
and then you're like, I
read, I turn that Skinner up.
And then you guys all shares each other
and then you go raping or Oh my God.
Hogging. That's what you called it. When
you go find, you know, big checks. Yeah.
And then you'd bang her.
Didn't you go hoggin?
No. Who had hogging this kid?
Craig told me about this.
I told you the whole story. He said
he was going Haagen what does that?
And he's like, come on man. You
know what Hoggin is? No, he's great.
You just go try to find the fastest check
you confined Fucker, you know? Yeah.
It's like, whoa. You've never
done that? No, of course not.
No.
Make it a game to hunt for fat chicks.
Rapey isn't as I bag thing to do. And
this guy was your best friend? No,
he's a guy that lived in the dorm.
There's a lot of weird fucking
people in that place. Oh
really? Yeah. In North Carolina. No Shit.
We used to call this one kid. What
did we call him? Gray. Here we go.
I call them like n word.
No, what we call them.
Like something.
It was something revolting,
like vomit or something
like that was his nickname.
He used to sleep on a
mattress with no sheets.
It was just like gray with stains
and just the most just vile,
really gross people. Yeah. Yeah.
There was definitely gross people all
over that hall and this guy with his
hoggin was pretty gross too.
I, it's so funny, I can't even picture
you living in north cal. Cackle Acca is,
as you say,
I can't picture you being,
I don't mean that there's
gross people in the Carolinas.
There's gross people everywhere. But I
was saying specifically my dorm hall,
just gross people there. Yeah.
There was this one Italian guy,
I don't know if I've told the story on
this show, I don't want to say his name,
but he was an Italian foreign
exchange student on our hall. Yeah.
And one time he woke up in the middle
of the night and a friend of our saw him
washing his penis in the men's
bathroom and they're like,
what are you doing dude?
He's like, go ahead
to wash him up INA soften to the sink,
wash your Dick off work because he
has an erotic get a wet dream. Yeah.
And he washes pinner off in the all
boys' bathroom or something. It's weird.
I always thought it was weird to
have coed shitters in um, colleges.
They do that. Yeah. We had a
separate, yeah, sort of way.
God see the girl next
door of being pounded.
Ron wanted to shoot it as wide.
All over my big boobs.
I finger myself at the same time,
watch the glory hole and these
bitches don't care who they suck.
Titus has pounded hard, wet
change, homeless black women
beyond that. So awful. Even for me. Jeez.
Yeah. Homeless black women. That was his
breaking point. Yeah. That's funny. Yeah.
That's what we liked. That
homeless black women. Yeah.
He's a racist. Right guys? We need
to boycott Lou Reed. He's a racist.
It's a really bad thing. Black cocks.
Wherever the social justice warrior. Yeah.
Buzzfeed.
Come on starting article.
Zoom his body and stab him.
Stab him for laughing at that guy.
Shouldn't laugh at certain things. No, you
should not. You should be told when it,
it's okay to laugh and when
it's not okay to laugh.
I believe in that wholeheartedly.
Guys.
Are we mocking the black female
homeless community out there that,
I mean the privilege of that man
has and is unaware of. It's just,
Ooh, I bet he used a gender specific
restroom before he read that too. Yeah,
I know. Yup. How dairy?
Somebody said they had a lung infection,
a picture
mommies. I was listening to episode
four 51 when something big dawned on me.
I couldn't believe how big it was.
My brother wouldn't believe it either.
He has no neuropathy issues.
He believes me now though,
and I'll start when you,
Hitler's began mocking that God's given
him raw art form of scatting only to
turn around and praise a lung infection.
Ramblings of a desert BG.
It occurred to me that the desert
BG could in fact be scatting.
According to Wikipedia,
scatting is a type of vocal music that
involves using nonsensical syllables to
sing non vocal dance tunes.
In my opinion,
the desert bgs,
lung infection loaded singing is largely,
if not wholly comprised of nonsensical
syllables and non vocal tunes.
What do you think? Anyway, my moose
soup is ready. Got to go. Thanks Zach.
Zack Hitler.
Zack, you're, I see your logic.
However it is flawed because we
all know that he's trying to sing,
staying alive.
It's not nonsense gibberish.
It's his version of staying alive.
Yeah. He's saying the words in his mind.
He's saying the words right. He's
trying write scat. There's no agenda.
There's no plan and scheme. Yeah, he's
a beeline. Stay be ah, ah,
AH,
stay beeline.
That's true. Well there
you go. There it is.
Who would you rather hang out with?
The No neuropathy guy?
I'm talking like a hang.
You guys go to a coffee house and you
have just a cup of coffee and you have to
talk and listen to what this guy says.
Yeah.
It's either the known rob Athey four
strokes. Yeah. Or the try it out guy. Oof.
Like you have to really talk to him.
Um,
or better yet you're stuck on an
airplane and it's a cross country flight.
And do we, who are you sitting next
to try it out? Or No neuropathy,
man.
I don't know. For stroke. What is
this for? Stroke. Anthem deal, man.
Somebody gave me a fourth.
Uh,
you're not answering my question.
You're distracted with the soundboard.
So answer my fucking question
either for stroke guy or try it out.
Oh, definitely. Hanging out
with for stroke. I first.
Why definitely you make it sound like
it's a no brainer because it is a no
brainer.
Why you could tell that
for stroke guy has like a level
of politeness to him. He's,
he makes points like I'm not trying to
make you do anything you don't want to do
and you don't believe in this.
Don't do it.
I'm not saying to do it anything you're
not uncomfortable with. Like he really,
he has awareness,
social awareness if you will.
He does the, the other. Yeah.
Guy Ipad.
Any kind of direct tau disorder problems.
I mean this guy, he's even
more articulate. It makes
me feel like there's more,
you know,
we don't think the try it out. Guy would
be fun because of the rambling. Yeah.
He'd be like, it's scary. Here's
the deal man. I got way, he's way.
He's way scary. Right. I kinda, I gotta
have this peanuts man. I got my other,
it really smoked with me. He put his dick.
I can't believe how big is stabilized.
He jacked off boards. Yeah, and
shot the most coffee every time. But
here's the problem with this here,
the neuropathy guy is that I have a
feeling he's going to be fixated on this
subject and you're going to have to
hear about the entire flight. Yeah,
but the other guy can't get off
of it. It might snap. He's really,
he's really fucking freaked
out. You know, he's freaked out.
But he might have tangent, tangential
thoughts and like interesting studies.
Gross.
I think he's pretty gross.
I think bad things happen when you're
around him. Let's try it out guy.
No fucking way. I take the
try it our guy. You know what?
Why don't want to hear about
him jacking his deck for four.
He's only going to talk about Dick Jacks.
That guy's going to talk about
pissing on him and beating.
It's more interesting than
the known neuropathy needs.
Know your app and your app and he knows
the mind his business when it's time now
near apathy. The other guy
does not really doesn't. Yeah.
Oh uh,
oh God.
You're disgusting. Tells me that.
Anyways. Do you think he's right?
No, I don't think that guys right. Zach's
not right. It's not scanning. No, no.
He was singing a fucking sending
a scouting is nonsensical.
It has no plan or rhythm.
It's random,
but that guy is clearly singing a version
of a song. You know what I'm saying?
Scat. There's no agenda. It's like
free form that this isn't free for him.
This guy has a plan and here's
another one. Dear Tyler,
Christine and I got to pay him.
After recently being the wedding,
I received a thank you
card from her that ended,
you are the reason my husband and I
started fighting in front of each other.
I managed to accomplish just amazing
feat by bringing up my friends,
horrible gas to her. Then
boyfriend, when I first met him,
now they consider me the hero
of their love story. Oh Wow.
Seeing as releasing bottom burbs can be
an important milestone in a relationship.
I would love to hear about the first
time you floated Airbus gets in front of
each other. Well, we've
covered this for sure.
You're covering the last
episode and it says,
do you think it's possible to go to entire
marriage that letting your mate here
a single, but I mean, this is literally
what we just talked about. Um,
well everyone knows the story
of me farting in front of you.
I don't even remember your first part,
truth, nor do why mine was
obviously really impressive, but
I don't recall. But I, you know,
we've been astounded by couples
that don't and don't Brown.
We don't brown in front of each other.
That's the last boundary we've maintained.
Really? Yeah, but we talk
about it constantly. We do,
but we don't actually like
browns. We just like, yeah,
no part, but I'm not going to shit
in front of you. I personally look,
it's not so much about the farting per se.
I feel like it's an intimacy barrier.
Like if you're not farting
in front of each other. Yeah.
Like what else are you lying about?
There you go. It's like lies to me.
It's a great thing to bring up to the
next person that doesn't want to Fart in
front of you. Like, why are you lying to
me? Right. It feels like it's not real.
I agree. How do you not for like 20
years, people hold in farts. Nasty.
You Want to take a quick pee break?
Yeah, I got to go see. I see. Yeah.
And we'll wait for Aerie. All
right. Uh, we did it and it's great.
We're back with
one and only Joe mother fucker.
Yo are,
you should be here for a second. We've
been so excited to play that drop all day.
I was like, why are you pausing? That's
a weird, oh that's it for hatred,
hatred. I mean what's
better than that guy? Yeah.
What is that from? That's from
Grifols. From Casino Casino. Okay.
Nice talking to cm. Rosene
fuck you mother fucker. Yo.
Fuck me. Fuck me. Fatso
I can't wait for the,
for the fucking liberal
movement to find the,
all square says these old
movies and be like, wait, what?
There's so much to boycott.
We were just talking about that.
We played a clip of Lou reed reading a
porno descriptions and I can just see the
social justice warriors pain cause
he lacks zoom his body and stab him.
He laughs at one point
he's made laughs uh,
black on black homeless
women and they were like,
well now they would just be like,
you know,
hates Titus has pounded hard with change,
homeless black women
beyond that. So awful. And now
they'd be like, is it, is it awful?
Awful though?
Louis a woman who's black,
marginalized by society and homeless
is something to laugh at. Oh,
so we laugh with people
getting downtrodden. Okay,
I see what you're saying.
I see what you're doing that cause
you're rich to think everyone downtrod is
worse. I got it. Bad side,
something to laugh that pull all
of his albums and ruin his career.
I mean are you,
are you kind of going like what the fuck
with how outrageous that shit is now?
Some of it's like naughty and it's the
pressure that's put on everybody to react
the same all the time. Right. The guys.
Because then we'll know what team
you're on. I know, but it's like,
it's like with normal people have to
in silence go. I can I talk to you?
I'm sorry. No worries. What
happened to that one guy?
I'm going to see people coming
and pick up your fucking pick it.
Yeah. Well that's crazy. With Elise,
the Chris Hardwick
thing is that that girl,
the accuser just wrote
like a blog essentially.
Like it wasn't even a vetted
article in a print. It was like,
Hey, here's just what I think
and then everything's gone.
Everything is just gone.
His careers, everything else.
So I don't think he did.
Even in her wish she wrote
it is sexual assault.
It's just like I really want to fuck
all the time. And it's like, okay,
well no deal from it. She said within two
weeks she was doing everything he said.
So if I'm to believe that there's
this sexual assault that was,
he must have a power over here.
So Chris Hardwick must be some sort
of demon or a wizard to be able to,
in two weeks for somebody, maybe he's a
pimp with longterm pit. It's like crazy.
It's walk away. Whether or not it's,
it's, it's like not even vetted.
There's no due process.
It's just like this girl says it and
now we don't know her mental state.
She was an actress. They're
all morons. Every one of them.
Even the ones who made it,
they're all fucking loopy.
Dipshits some of them are well read cause
they get a lot of scripts in front of
them. They are more Roz. You guys
have met actors, actresses, the guy,
actresses of justice,
bad solipsistic garbage.
Everyone's world where it was just them.
What about Johnny Depp's thing?
Have you read the recent interviews
of him and being broken? I that,
that's crazy. That's an
actor. You fucking moron.
How would you broke? You broke and
part of a franchise. They have the,
he got 30 million a flick
for though. What the fuck you talking
about broke? No, that's not an option.
They uh, they have an email in there from
him, from his business manager to him.
Uh, it's like from when they
were obviously still working
together and he's like,
Hey, I got to give you a warning.
I got to give you a heads up.
The holidays are coming up.
I need you to keep your holiday spending
within reason. And he writes back,
thank you. Uh, I appreciate what you're
saying, but also what am I supposed to do?
It's the holidays.
Have a family.
People rely on, they need
$5 million. He needs boats.
I don't know what else to say to you.
Um,
and he's like, do you want me to sell
art? If not, what do want me to sell it?
Like eight question mark.
What do want me to sell
more? It was like, oh, I need
something. Let me pause this.
Just a rich version of pawning,
something to be able to afford something
else because of what I can sell it.
Lord. I know his, his is, it really is
though. Like a psychological disorder,
I think. Like legit. No, no,
no, because they said, you know,
it is compulsive. Like 2
million a month. Just Bandanas.
2 million, $2 million
a month. Wow. I mean,
we're talking about spending $25
million a year and he's just like,
not enough.
I spent like two months,
but we both were in a Hong
Kong and bought suits. Huh. Uh,
I don't know what you spent on the
road I spent, how much did you spend?
I think 300 okay. He
went to Singapore. Okay.
He dropped 110 grand on suits. Well, see
if he had just gone across the water.
Hong Kong. I, by the way, when I
heard it was 300 I was like, what?
Tom Road? That'd be like, yeah man,
this is the guy who worked from,
now he's going to fuck you,
make you a nice suit. That's
way less than a thousand.
You're like, oh. I thought it was like 50
bucks just to a hundred grand on suits.
My favorite is 5 million on
shooting hunter s Thompson,
his ashes into the sky with a canon.
How much you spend on that?
They claimed that the article claim 3
million and when he was met with that,
he goes, that's bullshit.
It was five to shoot.
You can just get one of those
fucking to shirt cannons. Yeah.
I mean if,
and any type of business owner,
and Johnny Depp comes to
the room and says, Hey,
I'd like to do this thing that really
hasn't been done much, can you do that?
And I just, it my eyes turned to cash
signs and they go, yes, it will cost
5 million.
Try something to cost you 250 bucks.
And he's the guy who's,
who's definitely like whatever
you say. He's like, we got
to do it all right. Yeah,
because he also had emails to her. His
manager was a busy manager, was like,
you know, we got it. It can't
do this, this is your behind
on this. And he was like,
I need that house,
make it happen.
We have to have this house because he
bought like all these properties all over
the world. I mean, how many
houses? They were like,
can you sell your villa in France
that you don't go to? Like, no,
I heard somebody say,
this fucker for first sound like rockstar.
It might've been a beetle, might've been
someone else, but someone like that.
And um, he goes, oh, it was a
rolling stone. And he was like,
don't have too much of a nut.
Don't have your costs be too high because
then you will have to do things in
order to pay for that nut to a hundred
percent what he does. And he goes,
not for me. I have three nice
houses, one in New York, one in La,
one in London, and I have to
do some shitty commercials
sometimes to pay for it.
I don't want to do those things. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Now this is a, it's they,
it's crazy. How was he broke? He is the
guy on the thing you just talked about.
It's like get an allowance.
He is doing that. He's like,
they said like the whole thing is
always trying to get him to do work,
which he's happy to do.
Yeah. And he's like,
I'll make a fuck load of
money and we'll be all right.
And then he'll blow it all
immediately spend it all the crazy.
That's why you see them also in
those like weird. Um, you know
when you go to Asia to,
he's everywhere.
That's all so crazy buying his fucking
bullshit, man. Did you get a suit? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Wow. Yeah. I went to, yeah,
it was in Hong Kong. Yeah. It was great.
From Rhodes Guy, rocky.
No, but in that pavilion,
Danny's suit district is to district.
Yeah. You walk out of there with a soup,
you're like won a suit.
I'm like, I, I have over my
shoulder. Like come on, come on,
get another suit. You know what,
back to the, uh, the Hardwick thing.
But one thing that's kind of, I realize
is the difference now in culture is, um,
the, when you fire someone,
like when you're done with them,
that's what they judge you
now on is how swiftly. Yeah.
And in absolute and complete that is
done. So it's like, it was that day.
I think the Huh. It's crazy.
Cause I'd like to see what
happens. It's not my money,
so I can't really tell them, but it's,
I'd like to see what happens of a network.
Just refuses to comment, not says, not
such, which I love. It's like, Hey,
we've actually been working with this guy,
we're friends with this guy for a while.
Um, while we figure this out, if it's,
if it's right, that's terrible, but
we believe in the sky. He Says No.
So right now he's our buddy and if we
find out that it's that he's lying,
then you know,
we'll take actions that we have to,
but for right now that's been a
part of our life for a long time.
We're going to stand with them
instead of just ruin a dude's
life without any, to be honest.
That's all I'd want from any network is
just to shut your mouth and let me take
the heat, let the fucking heat
come at the person and say,
you could take our job at comedy
central for all they do. Good or bad.
They are great at just fucking
shutting up and they don't get,
they don't get involved. In fact, when
Tj had his thing and people were like,
comedy central, cancel the show,
they put out like, oh no, no,
that was canceled six months ago.
Don't put this on. Put this on us.
We actually did not get involved, which
is, that's great. That's all you gotta do.
Yeah. Just be like, don't go to
you. Yeah. Had an article is really,
oh my God, it's, it's strange.
The uh, you know, look, and I'm not
questioning the validity of her claims.
I'm not questioning factual, whatever,
but at least for the public's sake,
you know, at least if it's in print, they
have to vet these people are all idiots.
No stupid for us to be so kind of
fact finding flying with this shit
just happened. What, can you give
me a trick? Last spilled coffee?
Is it a hot no, it's not hot, but
I've got to think like coffee.
You're going to stink like shit. Ah, oh.
Well to fly home with a rotten
milk on you. Thanks buddy.
Hey.
But to not even explore the claim,
even explored sure that they're right and
that she's of sound mind and that this
is true.
It's just like off
McCarthyism. It's a form of a social
McCarthyism accusations. Enough. Aye.
Aye. Aye. Yeah. I'm on the side of these
accusations aren't even up something.
Fireable I don't know what you're
saying from the article. Yeah.
It's like what she's saying
easy. Even as like, I don't know,
he pressured you a lot and by the way,
when he says the first thing he said after
she had her surgery was going to have
sex, if he said that in front
of your mom, the fucking,
come on guys. What sees a
sociopath? Suddenly if he said it,
it was a complete joke. Yeah, no, I,
when I read it because I read it,
I'm like, that's funny to say. Yeah.
That is such a harsh overboard thing
to say. I'll never forget he said it.
I'm like, oh, come on. Yeah,
that was definitely a comedian making a
joke to release some tension in a room.
Right? You just had surgery. Yeah.
I think what the problem
is is that there's no sense
of context context anymore.
It's like you, you said the word that
nobody likes and now you're in trouble.
You did the thing that nobody likes
and it's like, well what about,
and they're going for like,
there's tons of ways to interpret
anything you say or do. Yeah.
So what's the worst possible way I
can interpret this? Right and no one,
what's the worst to me is when comedians
don't even look at that and go, hold on,
hold on, hold on. Yeah.
Can we look at what may be a positive
way he might've meant that? Yeah.
Like instead of just straight to like how
dare you. Yeah. It's fucking horrible.
It's scary. It's, it's kind of
scary. It is. Yeah, it is. But,
but like, I dunno where I didn't know.
You just got to keep your head down.
It's also a form of like ultra
conservatism. Do you know what I mean?
It's no better than being like on the
other end of that ultra liberal ultra
liberals are out of their
fucking minds. Yeah. Yeah.
The far left is they are far left.
That's a good way to say they are crazy
as shit crazy and they're completely
without any reason and they don't care.
And a big reason I think that they act
out in this way right now is because the
lies with the other side.
So Trump is in office and
he hit him saying bad daddy.
And it triggers the shit out of
other power sources.
A group mentality,
group mob on the Internet saying,
we want this guy gone and
having it happen. That's,
that's more powerful
thing Trump is right now.
And he's saying the motivation is because
the leadership is so, it's saying like,
we don't have the control,
right?
So what can we control and trusting
that control to not like leaders of that
side, but to fucking dummies. Yeah.
I don't want people who are the same
people that were beat you up because you
like the fucking writers
instead of the 49. Right?
Like that's a sign level person
from sports to fucking politics.
It is like really,
it's really bad the way the,
the conduct of, of what has
become the, the f I mean,
obviously both extremes are extremes
and they act like complete fucking
lunatics. The far left would eat their
young and they'll do [inaudible].
If you don't,
if you don't respond the way they want
you to respond to every situation,
that's it. They're there. They're fucking,
they're that far left. When you get your,
your father, when you get
your partner pregnant, um,
the number one thing they're
hoping for is a trans baby
crawl and then the far right. The funny
thing about the far right is that they,
they coined the term snowflake,
you know,
like that's what they, and they're the
biggest snowflakes. No, right. For sure.
The most sensitive,
easily offended.
They'll just lash out at you. Again, not
sharing a perspective. Then they're like,
fuck dude, obvious people are double
standards. Totally. No, they totally are.
Comics do that too. It's like they,
they shit on all these people for, for,
for taking like pride in their victim
hood and then they talk about some Twitter
response to what are their jokes for
an hour. It's like, all right, fuck it,
get on with it.
I feel like I don't exist in this world.
I feel like I just observe it, you
know what I mean? Like matrix style,
but like what you're saying
like, oh, the victim comedian,
that's like doing the hall,
I,
this thing happened to me and
I'm the victim and then how it,
but then it's how dare you.
Oh yeah. No, not even that.
I just mean comics talking about like,
I mean you had it with retard,
you know, like at some point like,
all right, get back to jokes.
Let people don't, don't us
also be the ones saying, well,
I had it hard because of this. Yeah.
He's like, came at me after this joke.
It's like, let them just go on
with it. Go on with it. Yeah. Yeah.
It's fun for promotion, but like if it's
a real, like how dare they, it's like,
it's fine. Let them, let them,
let them act like people walk,
walked out of my shell and like,
yeah, Eleanor, you're harsh.
You want a couple of people walking
out or it's too safe. Right.
You need those people. That's true. They
make the rest of the people enjoy it.
I tried to not engage this long time,
you know?
Really for sure. Well, you know what,
my dad always told me
what could ignore retard
by the Holocaust. You guys, you've
got to allow that. My Gosh. Yeah. I
do wonder
what the actual numbers are of people
that are genuinely offended by things or
I want to ask me about like are
you okay? I'll, I'll stop it,
but let me just tell me the truth.
Are you offended?
Are you trying to get
offended? Right? Which one?
Is it here or do you
wonder who's pissed off?
Do you want to feel the applause of
the people who hear you say that you're
offended because then they think of
you as this righteous. Yeah, Christina.
Yeah. Yeah. When tig goes, I don't know
what Louis Ck was thinking. It's like,
well you could,
I mean you have his number.
The better way to find out who's doing
an interview. It's just a call the guy.
Look, what were you thinking? When
you have a direct path to an answer,
you find fucking climbers.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Shut up. What are you in food? No idea.
The whole time you fucking
heard everything we had,
we heard whether you were
doing your fucking show with
them and get your show on
their fucking bull shit. Well, now that
I know, I'm glad my show is canceled.
You can always just cancel your own show.
You're just saying,
I'm not doing my show anymore. Yeah, you
have that power. I'm so glad this is now.
It's, I'm able to fuck shut up.
Shut up. Everyone's a hypocrite.
Yeah. Well, yeah, that's
interesting isn't it?
I mean, I'll go by, but Janeane
Garofalo who was like, yeah, I heard it.
We heard about Louie. I was at that
fucking festival. We all laughed about it.
You've got a different time and it is
a different person than he was then we
heard about it and our response was
laughter. That's Janeane Garofalo yeah.
And now you're a bit like, how dare
you. It's like we heard it them, uh,
during the time it happened, we weren't
as harsh as you guys are now. Right.
So like,
it's suddenly we're supposed to be mad
about something that happened a long time
ago.
I'm trying to think of when the started
and I'm texting with a friend of mine
who's a professor in university and he
says to me today that the students are
now asking him to give them
trigger warnings. Yeah.
His lectures and asking if they can read
their own books cause they don't want
to read what's being assigned.
And that some woman wrote an open letter
to the dean open letter complaining
that they were, they were assigned
to read Shakespeare and that, um,
that, that, that, that is part
of rape culture and you go,
well how did this get slick work?
Is this,
is this because of this veal generation,
this millennial generation race? So,
so stringently that now they're adults
and they don't understand how the real
world functions because their parents
have fucking Molly coddled them and put
helmets on them and made everything safe
and secure and now they're in the world
and they can't fucking deal.
I don't think, I think I'll
just start doing that, I think.
Have you ever known safe space
rooms meltdown? No. Like that. Oh,
is that what they're called?
Yeah. Yeah. Safe space rooms.
I thought that was all comedy is that
there's a high overlap for sure. But, uh,
there's, there's a meltdown was
a safe space room for a while.
They had it as a safe space for him and
it was a called that it could just be
the individual shows it got gut
book. Yeah. That's the genre almost.
They have like urban knights, they have
six space. Nothing is going to offend you.
Yeah. You just can't do anything there. I
don't even, I mean sure. It's, it's funny.
Is it two hours ago I guess,
and thinking about his,
his catalog,
Chappelle stopped in to meltdown and did
like that first round like trans stuff.
And that's where that like big blog, oh
yeah. Blew Up, came out. She was like,
I was here and I was initially excited
to see who I thought was a great
comedian. But then you wanna hear
something funny about that. Um,
a friend of mine was like, yeah, I was
there. Uh, when he did that, you know,
cause it's half comics.
Yeah. And he was there.
I was there and I was sitting next to the
person who wrote that blog and she was
dying laughing the entire time. Yeah.
And then later it's like, well hold on.
How can I get, well, I mean,
are you thinking that with
the amazing race and stuff?
And people are like,
how dare you? And if I,
if I like actually right on pathway to
human, I was like, come on, come on.
Those aren't, that's not real. It's
fucking calm down. They'd be like, well,
I have to admit I kind of kind of where
from the provost when I saw it and then
he went to a fucking raise and say, well
by die from, from laughing at first. Yeah.
So it's all ridiculous. Are you going
to say about the safe space room? Oh,
so they do these, what was I gonna say
about it? They do these sat scores.
They're fine with me to to put on.
It's just like, I don't know if that's,
if you're really kind of don't want
comedy that infringes on that at all.
It's fine to have those rooms.
So colleges that safe space room,
but just know that if I now go to a club,
I'm not going to get that.
So like once you're out of here
in college, you're going to,
it's going to be real world again,
but it's okay if you just want a
nice fun bubble to like, you know,
it's kind of silly that they even provide
that for you though because it's not,
it's not preparing you for the real
world at all. Well, in other ways it is.
How so? I mean, learning how to
put put memos and your boss's desk,
it prepares you for like legit things.
Well yeah,
but I'm saying it doesn't
prepare you for the safe spaces,
safe spaces that doesn't prepare you.
It's just a safe environment
which you can learn,
I guess when you're like Yale or
Princeton, a few years ago who was like,
I'm like screaming in the professor's
face because he suggested something that,
you know,
I'm also supposed to be safe.
It's a safe thing.
And what's not going to trigger somebody?
Let's say I one time choked
on cookies as a child.
And you mentioned that you had cookies
for lunch and now I'm triggered the fuck
up. Yeah. I always want to know what
the line was. What percentage of people,
how to have been through something before
you can, can you talk about murder?
If someone's been murdered,
can you talk about like what,
what's not triggering to me? I know a
lot of things trigger and it's also like,
you know,
you might get triggered,
I dunno what's triggered a
memory of something emotional.
Yeah.
And emotional association with something.
Maybe I went to see a panorama
last year. I went to see, uh,
um,
the,
the festival Panoramio Sorta went right
from Montreal and nine inch nails was
playing.
I just had a friend hang herself like
three weeks before and he started doing
hurt and he does it so well.
And I,
I'm balling just because of the, are the
lyrics because it's, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everyone loved goes away in the
end. Just like, it's just so sad.
Fucking pick Jay's
daughters right next to me.
Just stare at this adult fucking
crying with flip flops on and uh,
but like,
yeah,
I guess I was triggered into thinking
about people that were important to me and
that made me sad. But like,
it's so bad. Yeah. Like what?
You're allowed to be true.
It's okay to be that you can be
what
everybody wants to
feel. I think, you know,
part of this is a generational pushback
on the fact that care about different
things.
Well know that the generation before us,
like our parents were raised and
the whole world was like, yeah,
I'm like, it's not fair. This is hurting
right now. Me Emotionally, they're like,
what are you fucking stupid? Like yeah,
that's the word they use. Stupid. Yeah,
that's for sure. The word that they
use, it was like magnet but different.
I'm the negative. Like it's an, it tells
you a mag. And partially because they,
you know, they didn't know. They didn't,
they never knew to be emotionally aware,
basically. So if you're like,
something's bothering you,
you wouldn't express it.
They wouldn't get it out of you.
They wouldn't coach you through it
because they weren't raised like that.
And then we'll move into the
era where they're like, hey,
you can be really in touch
with feelings and emotions.
And then that gets heightened so much to
overcompensate for an entire era where
nobody did it. It feels like
that's almost kind of pick up.
Then the gen x or is have raised the
millennials, the Gen Ed, we're gen x.
We were raised by that generation
that was like fuck it soldier on.
Put your head down.
Don't talk about your feelings.
So we fucked up the world basically then.
Cause then we raised our kids to be like,
you need to have feelings.
This safe place. We a helmet. When
it's an extreme, it's too much.
It's too much. It's just terrible.
By the way, don't call me again.
I was born in 88 I don't know what you're,
you're on the,
you're not not millennial gen x.
That's nirvana bras younger than you.
I don't know what you're talking about.
79 or 80 is the cutoff.
Okay,
so 84 so that means for my ass,
definitely younger than you.
I was born in 1993
I check it out. Look what I'm
growing up. Your Jew Curls? No,
I thought that in there and I was like,
that was kind of racist to point out.
Why are you doing that for? I'm
doing this hour and Edinburgh. Oh,
for your two hour play area. So we're
trying to grow them out a little bit.
My girlfriend hates it. She's
like, what? Get a girlfriend.
You have a girlfriend? Yeah.
Wait, how do we not know this?
But I don't want us, I don't know
much about her. I don't want,
we just had a very cutting. Tell
me this. God. It's been a while.
How long has it been? I don't
even know. What does she do?
Art Curator in New York.
Yeah,
you can text me this.
What am I going to do fucking in the
conversation and let you guys burn on me.
Just fucking send me a message. I
have a girlfriend. I love her so much.
Gave her kisses all the time.
I would never ever do that.
Do you guys living together
in sin? Okay. First of all,
the point of all this was look at
these jokers. Wait, is she Jewish? No.
What does she think of it? She really
hates it. She's like her garbage.
Does She Christian? No. Why would, I
wouldn't want her to convert for me.
When you guys get married getting married,
he marries you.
Yeah. They used to do that thing. We were
like, you hit your own back, right? No.
Flagellation and then you tie the
tie the box you did. We tried to tie
the box so tight. This was our, what?
We are bad asses.
We would be time.
So tied that to see how many
periods that would last.
Like the annotation with last.
Once you take them off you have to go
through breakfast and first period like
check it. Oh, what? What era were you the
most hardcore you think in your belief?
Like if somebody would ask, if somebody
were to stop you and be like, Hey,
are you into this? You'd be like, the fuck
are you asking me? Like, of course I am.
Yeah. Yeah. When I was in Israel and your
Shiva and like how old were you then?
20 Oh, so 20 your your
die hard. Die Hard. Wow.
Died pretty. That's
pretty grown up. Fuck it.
You were convinced to this is your path.
I mean, I hadn't really thought about it.
Yeah, but like for Shai, what age
are you like, no, of course not.
This is 21. God Damn. During,
I think after I turned
21 I was really like,
I think I might be out and then just done
what the hardest conversation to have
with family. Yeah. Probably.
I remember when I had to tell my dad
about being a serial rapist and that was
difficult, but this was far, far harsher
when you tell him that this is the worst
thing to tell him. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
This was Harvard.
I didn't believe him.
He's not as hardcore as you
were at 20. Right? He is.
He is that hard core about
that hardcore. He's sly. He's,
he's like loosened up a
bit. Um, like he was like,
get a fucking burger if you're around
me. They don't curse. I'm sorry. He's,
but he's like, you can get a burger.
It's okay. Yeah, yeah. But like, yeah,
he's like, why, what am I fighting for?
You know, people, it's calmed down. Yeah.
It's funny,
my parents used to,
I mean I didn't have anything that
was intense is what you were doing,
but you know,
it was just never a question that you
would obviously go to church on Friday
obviously. So whenever I came home from
college on Sunday, it was like, Hey,
are you ready to go? Not even like you're
coming today, right? Oh, you're ready.
Ready? And like I would just go and
then it's like out of college, you know,
conversations like,
yeah, to get phone calls.
Like are you going to church out there?
And I'd be like, yeah, all the time.
I'm an ally.
I didn't want to do the line anymore.
But then they came out and that would
have to like find a church to go to and,
and then,
and it was like Christina would come with
Christine would come with me home and
we would go and there would be things
like we'd sleep in let's say when I came
home to visit. Yeah. And then it's
like, uh, you know, they're like,
well, you missed the, you know, the 11
o'clock and you can still make yeah.
And I'd be like, yeah, we're
going to try to go later.
And then they would kind of check on
that. Did you go? And I was like, no.
And then he'll look, what am I
doing? Can I just say this already?
Then he would never go, well they did
this thing where they would bring it like,
you're not going to go to church this
week or something. And it would be like,
I don't think so. And they were
like, okay. And then locked it out,
see how it played, plays, look
at them. And then there was, uh,
the one when I knew I would,
I had actually done it,
made the leap and that it was
like not an issue anymore.
I mean it was, this was years obviously
like, you know, cutting down the time,
but it was just like
Sunday and they're like,
or a Saturday night and they're like,
um,
I'm gonna pick up a coffee on the
way home from thing tomorrow or like,
do you want me to bring you a coffee
or something? I'd be like, yeah.
And they're like, okay. And then
no, uh, no mention of it. No guilt.
Like they would just show up and be
like, got your coffee. Need, why?
Argue with them? Like, do what
you want to go see a movie today.
Like they're just not a big moment.
That's a huge, where I was like,
I don't have to pretend anymore. And
then now like they used to, you know,
always be like, are you my mom? Not My
dad. My mom be like, are you praying?
I was like, yeah, and now she
doesn't, she doesn't even know.
Sometimes she'll be like, do you
think God for like all your blessings?
And I'm like, oh definitely. I
definitely never think my agent
so,
but it is funny how,
I mean it's really like
it does, it does. It is,
you feel kind of Shitty when, when you
feel like you're breaking their heart.
I know it's us, but then at some
point like I just can't do it for you.
Kevin Meaney and my
podcasts before he died,
talking about coming out of the closet,
a 50 years old and it was like he didn't
want to hurt his dad when his dad died.
He could come out. But it's like she
would place your entire sexual life yeah.
For not being free because of offending
or hurting the, but did he die of,
is it cancer? Uh, I don't know. No,
I'm not sure. That was like two years
ago. Yeah. You don't know what he died of?
I don't know. It sounds like
aids. I assume it's, yeah,
I think he just thought,
I don't know what he died of fat too.
Not like huge fat, but like,
but like I had a belly on him.
He's been gaining a lot
of weight. Bert? Yeah.
They called me and he's like, I'm getting
so much. And I go, why? He was like,
I ran that marathon.
That was so long ago.
How long do you think the afterburn
last? He's like, I know, but
um, hold on. This is coming out of
the closet was hard on my parents.
But you had to do it to your parents?
Yeah, no, I mean a about religion.
I thought you meant it for you guys.
And what were you going to show me?
What he could show me? You know, I
just saw that he had posted this thing.
He did that, the tour with those
guys over the weekend. Oh yeah.
Where did he post a? Just
like 48 but like, oh my God,
look what a piggy Jesus, this
little piggy went to disease.
See it. It's like, that's
big man. By the way,
Canadian Berg Gatsy love this picture
because they're like, oh, I'm fine. Oh,
they're like, what am I,
one 50 this? Yeah. I mean,
it takes up most of the screens. Look,
CGI is distended and everything. Yeah.
It's really, it's really
sad. He's real big. I mean,
he must get out of the chair the way
Chris Christina gets out of a chair,
like pregnant belly first and
then let the weight push you up.
You've been going hard. I bet if we did
the Wayne's right now, you'd be like,
Oh fuck. I bet he wouldn't weigh
on publicly right now. No, no.
I asked him about it recently. He was
like, it's just bloat. It's bloke,
it's bloat from liquor. And
I'm like, so that means if you,
if you stopped within like a couple
of days to be back to normal.
One is a bloke and he's, I don't
know, become subject change. Yeah.
Well that's the thing is like, it is
probably directly related to that. Yeah.
Which is directly related to
touring right in the road.
You're never going to stop.
He's never going to stop
touring. No, absolutely. Yeah.
Absolutely not by the way. Um,
I know a lot of like when Ralph,
he got the stomach stapled, people were
like, he needs to go see a therapist.
Now sometimes it's not enough to
cover up what's wrong with them. Sure.
So I think a lot of what's
Burt gaining that weight?
It's because of the guilt.
Those children. I mean,
cause he was working out a lot and
running and then suddenly he gains weight.
Right about the time he refused to give
that money that he owed to the children.
Yeah. Sad. We all donated for him. Yeah,
we did that. Does that the uh, children's
hospital. Children's hospital. Yeah.
If you guys want to donate,
it's a go fund me.com/evil Bert and uh,
we're trying to raise the $10,000. Did
he said it was going to, now he's saying,
I guess now he's saying that he never
even intended to give that money.
Crazy. Yeah, I remember him saying and
it calling me on and telling me about it.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh wait, when are you
doing? Uh, Edinburgh's is it August?
All of August 2nd pool. Have you done
it before? I've done it twice before.
Do you like this? I love it. I
mean, I think I'm the only American,
but sounds like Bronston or
people like that, that like that.
Like it sounds joyous.
So yeah,
I'm definitely one of the Americans
that doesn't because I would hate to be
somewhere for a month. What? What?
Oh, okay. I see my beautiful.
Um, they would hate to be
there for a month. Yeah. Okay.
Imagine I wouldn't hate
being an Edinburgh,
but I'd hate to be anywhere for a month.
Do you have a place though?
It's like a new home. But you're
doing what? 30 days in a row?
25 days in a row in a row? No, I don't
like that either. One day off. Ah,
Monday the 13th. Why is it every
fucking day, man? It's just,
but it's just only an hour a day.
You're free.
No, but you're not, you're,
you're never relaxed because the whole
day or thinking about your show that
night, you're never really, you can't do
anything at time. Where are you doing it?
Number for both. You are fucking
faggots. There's no way. Pablo. Um, I,
I did eight shows in a row like
a year ago somewhere. Oh, no, no.
Some were here and I was like, dude,
it's a marriage. And I was like, come on,
it's a marathon. It's a marathon. It is
like a thing you've got to get up for,
but you don't barely have to get up.
And then you're,
and then you have the full range of shows.
Right. I guess if you're doing 25 yet,
you have a heart.
Do you have train wreck shows?
Do you have like there are better and
worse shows? For sure. For sure. For sure.
Yeah.
Um,
but I saw those guys out there doing
their fucking crazy UK theme hours. Yeah.
And I was like,
I saw the first year I just
did my storytelling show
and the next year I did my
own.
But just regular American,
you're transitioning to a European guy
and then it's like, no, I'm not sure.
This comedy, you're
transition. Yeah, he is.
He's dog dot Tran's comic
started growing your hair out.
How? Who would be an uglier woman?
You are Tom [inaudible] or Tom,
who's the Uglier Trans Woman?
I mean, I know what the answer is. What
is it? Oh No, you do know it's done.
No, no, but you're so
tall and you're so lanky.
Tall like Grace Jones. Yeah, but your
bro, like your shoulders are bony.
Yeah. Let me see. Hi shoulders.
That means it only show weight.
Do you think you'd be an attractive woman?
If you are trying to think.
I'd be a five and a half and me, I'd
be like, I take it. You wouldn't have,
you wouldn't have to be drunk to fuck me.
You would have to be buzzed, but not to.
What about me? No, you wouldn't
have. It would be a fetish.
It would be like a northern
type of person. We're
hideous. Yeah. Would be like,
it'd be like, oh, people
want to punish themselves.
The same type of people who want you
to shit on their chest during sex,
but also want to fuck you.
Have you ever, by the way,
because we know God only
knows the nightmares you've
been involved with in your
sexual history.
Then with one of these absolute,
have you been with a woman
that's a total fucking surprise.
Mental case with what she likes.
Oh, what she's into. Yeah. Yeah,
because I imagine that you have been
with just the full drags, right?
Cogging come on.
Do you ever go hogging what's hugging?
Like where you just go out and just
try to find the fattest check possible?
Like AAA stuff? Yeah, it definitely
allows that. Does that? Yeah.
Just as a way to that. I do not
go hogging. Ah, no I do not.
I've wound up with a hog not
knowing how it's happening at all,
but I've been pheasant hunting
and wound up, so wait a minute.
Have you been though with a
real fucking, oh my God. Yeah.
I mean I almost hooked
up with somebody in,
in Scotland a few years ago
that I was like, hmm, this
might be it, dude. Oh really?
Yeah. Where I had to start
showing once it hit my brain,
I started showing people like
pictures and they were like,
I could go out of the way. I don't know
Asian. Wait, but you saw there their junk,
right? No, I didn't get,
I didn't get that. Oh,
have you ever had like a request though?
Like I'm saying as far as, you know,
not necessarily shitting on,
but something where you're like,
that was fucking crazy request.
Uh,
like bossing them around in a way,
like make him crawl around on the floor
and do chores for me. Ask for it. Yeah.
Yeah. And then some of them, I can't
give that to them enough. I'm like,
I can only to meet you so much
before it gets weird for me.
I'm fighting Ari's a better woman.
Cause he's a little nervy saying it's
not a question. Yeah. Now wait a minute.
Who would be worse and worse
as a woman? Me? Yeah. Or Diaz.
Oh, okay. Oh, this is easy.
This is easy. It's, he has
to be a worst woman. Oh Man.
Going to be the worst of all time.
Maybe grow
his fat is a male fat too. It's not
like a, it's not, it's pushed out.
You look honestly,
Christina,
you look like a how to draw
things to see jaws shape.
And then another smaller circle,
circle, circle like leg circle.
I'm in the very end of it.
This is my due date
is uh, is uh, they're doing this new
thing where it's, um, well, okay,
this is a fake one, but then I'll
give you a real one in a second.
But that were men are trying
to be closer to the uh,
baby by drinking the fluids,
the salary, placenta.
We've heard this. Yeah.
This is disgusting.
Can I tell you guys the most baller thing
to do? The best way to show your love?
Yeah. Okay. Having a baby
together. Your sperm.
Your Vagina. Yeah. Um, that's
an a great act of love.
But so sexual love, which is part
of it. It's how you get there.
The most baller,
most sexual thing you can do
[inaudible] is while Christine,
interesting is giving birth.
Like when she's like pushing out are
fucking the baby back here. Okay.
Sorry. So you're saying you
guys don't love each other.
This is so disgusting.
You say it comes out in my terms that
the relationship will always be about you
guys hooking up and they have to,
oh,
well back be quiet
at the moment.
How would you do it? Get under her maybe
like split level bed with one of those,
um, those, um, massage head things.
I mean, just what is, it's very,
the one take me up on, I'm going
to write a blog tonight. I,
social justice warrior
Aries art meets him.
I don't understand why you won't,
it's it, just show it to me.
Then the three of you closer
as a family. Oh, Mike,
this is pretty gross right here.
Somebody wrote in, let me tell you,
tell me if you ever done
anything like this. So here's
an email. Hey, Mommy's, uh,
I recently had something new happen with
my girlfriend when we were having sex.
I had to pee really bad before
we started having sex. Oh,
we'll start to get into it. And I
was like, fuck it. The peak and wait,
I've got a boner and it needs attention.
So we start to bang and after
about 22 to 24, good through us,
I shoot my load into my girl's vagina
immediately following this in voluntarily
start peeing and her as
well as you would expect.
She was not happy that I emptied my urine
load into her and we haven't spoken in
days. I'm pretty sure she's
getting ready to move out.
If you ever heard of this happening
before, does it have a name?
I told my friends and we settled on all
nerd, an Arnold Palmer half and half,
half p half come to any thoughts
on how to avoid this happening?
Case series. Thanks. You guys are
the best. Try it out. Dr Nick. Yeah,
I have an idea on how you can
avoid this out of the bathroom.
Just take a leak and uh, that's it.
That's the end of my explanation.
Joy to paint is oh no, no, no.
I mean I wonder how bad he had to pee.
If it was like if it was a 10 and he
rejected it and then his body was really
like,
you have to empty this right now.
That's the only way I can imagine not
being able to control. Once you do it,
can't pinch dreadful. Let it all go
out. Right. Why did you say your food?
You're pissing, can't you just pull
out and pee on the bed versus ego like,
Hey, that's a lot of calm.
A lot of conflict may be
filling you up. And he's like,
hold on, don't move. Which is like, um,
how gross would it be to have
BPD a shit rude. It's rude.
I'd be so upset. I mean, you know
better than, because it would probably,
what would it do to you?
I could give you all kinds of infections.
I'm shutting her out too. Yeah,
we could try it out. Yeah.
It's like athlete's foot of the Pussy.
That's a piss on it.
He's done it before this.
Inside a vagina. Yeah. No,
but I have docked with a dude and piss.
We've both pissed inch
in each other's holes.
What ice cream cones together with rocky
road is put on a peppermint. Does this,
that year 20 in Israel? Um, no.
I've never pissed inside
a woman done that. No.
You have to make a decision. Like
I maybe got lost in it. I'm like,
well this is already going in there.
I'll keep going.
How would you empty at handstand?
Walking with her legs up to the
bathroom to empty. Yet afterwards. That
falls on the bat, but then why? Why
not just pull out in the first place?
That's what I'm saying.
I mean I think we're all in agreement.
This man made an error just as a bad
thing to do. You don't want to do this.
I mean I could see this breaking up.
Your question
for your area, would you,
if you're super broke,
what'd you sell your shit to somebody
like would you shut up his bag and then
like sell it to somebody or would you
shit through a hole in a hammock and led
that person eat your shit.
Do what I'm saying like a really all
you're doing is something you do anyways,
but someone else's really enjoying it.
Listen,
I don't want to like be a
broken record on this podcast,
but it's kind of the same as that fucker.
Would you rather with big retarded.
I mean I want to do that anyway. I
want to shit in the stomach. You do.
If we could get a hammock situation where
you get somebody pay me all the better
because then you're a good crowd.
You know you got free tickets,
you're not as good at crowd but you
pay me and I shit in your mouth.
I went have to be broke.
I'm saying I'm down for that.
Would you let someone shit in
your mouth and absolutely not. No.
For 100 bucks though.
Sure. Blocks? No, no.
Come on.
Sit down.
They have my card is
McAfee
got sick.
I didn't agree with that.
She's talking about Hardwick.
Yeah.
It's a no brainer for you. I would
for sure would you not the first time
I'd be embarrassed at first
she likes it and never had done that.
She texts growlers till you can sound
to shifting his mouth.
I feel like every time is that easy
but yeah, there's money on the table.
Every time I take a shit without somebody
there and you save water on water
flush constantly.
I think also she probably got to the
point that one was probably like,
just have breakfast. I got to
get over it. Mcafee's house.
Is he jerking off all this happening?
Well, they don't talk about this,
but we always assume that has to be tight.
They'll reveal secrets. Tiger lover.
I think it has to. It
has to be yes. So yeah,
cause I can't just be the joy of
having it in your mouth or I could be,
it's good to be that fantastic. But isn't
there some sexual gratification there?
Hassle if he's not jerking it in
front of them as they share. Yeah.
But then he's waiting, I'm sure
a later jerk off course. Yeah.
I wonder how you'd, how you build that
fetish. That's what would that one really,
I mean, you would have to happen by
accident. Like this guy, that word in.
I mean that was all, that's all he could
do. This is how girls, that's interesting.
So it's, it's an accidental thing
and then you're like, oh wow,
this is a doorway to something I'm
really interested at. My name is
John McAfee.
Is that a fan? Yeah, somebody, man.
That's great. Could you use your time
escaping dad? He always missed John. Man.
It was fucking readmitted.
Make
good ones. That's, um, yeah,
he's nasty. He's fucked up man.
You just net bro. Ever
done crystal meth? Ari?
I would like to you can you
live in the city? They sell it.
Did we found a bag of fucking drugs
at this festival last weekend,
two weekends ago. And it was just
like, oh, what are we going to do?
Did you take him?
No.
So we have to find it on the road
back to camping at, at firefly.
So we're like going back
to where everybody camps.
It's guy's such a psycho stopped.
They're just hell. I was a miserable.
It looked down,
there's a Baggie full bag.
And I went to tie my shoes and fucking
palmed it did, there's powder pills,
everything powder. This powder. It's one
of those little tiny drawbacks, you know?
And uh, so our, our buddy that was there
with us, he's, he's just the trier.
So we're a luck. Let's give it to him.
Let's give it to him and see what he,
he tried. It goes, it's either
really shitty coke or amazing coke.
Oh. Like he didn't know and we didn't know
what to do with. Should take it or not.
And what happened? His girlfriend was
like, do not take it. We have other drugs.
We brought other drugs to do, we don't
need to do this fucking street drug.
And um, we ended up just doing the other
drugs. Yeah. I wouldn't take drugs.
I'd found on the, on the ground.
I normally would not. What do you,
do you stick to just like psychedelic
stuff or do you fuck with it too Molly?
Sometimes ketamine once in
awhile. Yeah. That's more
recent. That's pretty fun. One.
I Dunno, but I want to try heroin.
Would you want to try heroin? No.
You don't know. That's a horrible
one. Cause the addiction,
take that out and don't you want to
try it? You want to feel what it,
what it must be feeling. Yeah. Yeah. I
get what you're saying. Don't you want to,
so are you going to have, but what about
just another opioid, but why don't you,
why don't you go straight to heroin? Just
try something else. I mean, what's a,
I'll try shit.
Was it methadone?
Methadone's right. So I'm saying I
don't want to do oxy and say it's like,
just like heroin.
I'm like,
let you fucking try heroin and tell you
what's like heroin needle and really
start going, no bro. No, I don't want to
go needle right away and like smoke it.
Smoke done that accidentally
when I was 15 at a party.
Yeah. And I just accrue.
Yeah, he's got a, I just spaced out
watching the easy stitch commercial.
All my parents ended up coming
to the party and taking me home.
Like it you just kind of,
yeah.
You should do math though. Makes
your Dick Super hard. Yeah. Yeah.
You'll come faster and harder
than you ever come to you.
You won't believe how big your Dick
yets you've known neuropathy issues.
I'm not interested in Beth.
What,
why a little speed with like in
some ecstasy maybe, but not math.
Wow. Okay. So what is your lady party?
Sounds like it, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The same kind of drugs. Yeah. It's
mostly the second art gallery curator.
No art curator.
So like people would go to them like
they're building the fucking the Hudson
yards. And I need to like
art for the whole thing.
And so like there they find
artists and I don't know. Yeah,
she has, her job is to go to
galleries fucking twice a week.
It's such a fun job. It's like I don't
want to come gallery often with me today.
I'm like, alright. Hmm hmm. Hmm.
Hmm. Hmm. It's exciting. Sorry.
That's good. Do you like it?
What goes in the gallery? Yeah,
it's okay. It's fine. Yeah. Yeah. How'd
you meet Edinburgh? Two years ago?
What? We've got a festival flag. She was
there in Grad school. She from Oak town.
The, that she was that
the town? Yeah, sure.
Wait, sorry, I just had to back up.
So you go to these festivals like you go
to Coachella. I haven't been there yet.
I'll go next year. Oh, the burn the
burning man. You're into that. Yeah.
But you like these borrow for sure.
Love Bonnaroo. You love. What do you,
what do you like most about
the festival lifestyle?
Is it that where you have comedy
festival line festivals? Yeah.
I mean the music sounded
like just standing in line,
standing in line to take a
shit or p. Dot. Great. Yeah.
So you're just focusing on the negative.
So do you,
are you the open urination kind of guy?
What did you just piss in front of
people and stuff? You just piss on
your courtship Porta potties. They're
everywhere. I know. Civilized people do.
I'm asking you about. Oh
yeah, they all do that.
Or I'll pee in this in this actually this
fucking thing. Yeah, that'll MTL later.
Wash it out.
Oh, why not? And then drink water out of
it later. Not right away, but yeah, later.
Shove your Dick and misty.
It's wide mouth that gets right.
Okay guys, you've got no, you've got
no vacuum. Splashbacks situation. Yeah.
Are you one of those guys at
pease and cops in your house?
Oh, hi guys. I'm a fucking grown up.
I pay one of the house too and it bottle.
You got the toilet a lot of times. Yeah.
Most of your ps are in
toilet. Oh yeah, those at all.
Now do you fart in front
of your girlfriend?
No. But will there be a fart barrier
that you break at some point you think
[inaudible] I try to
time shit and the shower.
You and I are both in the same boat
on that? Yeah. The shit show crew.
Does she know about that? Uh,
not completely, but she says,
she mentioned offhand that like
what's your morning ritual?
Why you in the shower so long?
If I almost that just running cold
water while I fully shit and then so you
can't the fucking gone,
they might come out and you know,
then I cup a handful of this
is maybe different from you.
A couple of handful coat it with toilet
paper to catch the blood droppings
and then make my way to the shower,
turn the hot on and then
bleed out in the shower.
Did she know about, has she seen the
Juke lamb? She does not. No she doesn't.
I would tell her not to watch that.
All right. Yeah. For Brown, Brown,
Brown,
Brown bread.
Oh he's got that Brown,
Brown, Brown, Brown,
Brown. You know what you
need. You need a washlet
Bobby Kelly for the first time, just
like yours. And I really used it.
I used to it. You move it up
and down, you've shifted right?
Left like a claw for your ass.
It's great.
But the only problem with
that is as a bleeder,
I don't know when it's just water
dripping back down off it or it's still
bleeding out.
Well then you can take an exploratory.
Why do you ever check that thing out
with a doctor? He said it's cool to go,
good to go.
We don't mean good
stuff.
Yeah.
Then it slows down, but
sometimes, most of the time,
sometimes it just keeps going.
When does that happen?
I don't know.
I think it might be spicy food and
mature and so I'll walk around often with
just a plug up my bud.
What do you mean?
Yes, like a Tampon, but just rolled
up toilet paper half in. Mostly out,
soaking up the fuck you.
So is it soaked with,
uh, I was on jury duty last year
and it soak through to the pants.
Underwear.
You gotta try Maxi pads or at small
Tampon? Try Maxi Pad. I'll do,
wait a minute, is that okay? That was
not okay with to my doctor. I'm like,
are you sure we shouldn't do
something? And goes, it's a operation.
So fucking annoying and awful, but I'm
almost to the point where I'm like,
I'm just going to get it.
You gotta you gotta get it.
Might not even doing anything. You could
do a new European hour on it, you know,
trans, trans, trans comic hour.
Do you know what they're trying to get
people to say now instead of trans,
because they're saying trans
is or like, uh, it's like, uh,
they're saying one just do short
and things. It's like negative.
They want everyone to call them.
I swear to God on those trainee sexual,
no,
but that's more to this more pejorative,
but the heads of leaders in charge of
the trainee sexuals or saying that that's
what you should,
this is thought to be a really
lengthen it trainee sexual training.
Sexual is less offensive and trans. I
disagree, but they're crazy these days.
There has to be a website where
we can keep up on all the trainee,
sexual.com please. Okay, let
me look at it. But seriously,
can you please try a maxi pad or a Tampon?
I will give you some before you leave.
And you're still a periods while you're,
while you're pregnant. No, no, that's,
that's one positive and tampons.
Well,
here's what came up when I
headed and training sexual.
A lot of results though.
35 million.
I don't think you made two words.
It's one word. It's transsexual.
Homosexual. It's one word. Still.
Hobos. A bag and homosexuals.
Fine. 20 sexual. Yeah.
This is not coming with anything that
you told me about and maybe I'm ahead of
the curve. Yeah, that's possible.
But when I look at transsexual,
yeah, that comes up more. Oh yeah.
Well what a patriarch or
we live in still look,
trans woman. Trans is, yeah. Oh,
can you type in, it's just the difference
between transgendered, transsexual,
transgender, and Transylvania.
Dania, let's see what comes up.
It's very childish and sensitive.
Very sensitive,
or your podcast or you can
just sensitivity trader
right here that go here.
Oh boy. Do you know how I
went around the horn or no,
it was was a PTI. No, around the
horn. And they have a guy, um,
the stat boy correcting everything. No.
What's PTI like? What did we get wrong?
Let me get wrong. Yeah. Fucking one
of those people telling us that,
oh, here's a long whole thing had
already said about transsexuals.
It's completely wrong,
but corn starch.
So here we go. Oh, for, oh,
here's some, try it out. So
that came in, um, you know our,
about our tryouts, right? Wait,
I think I had one of these in Edmonton.
Somebody came at me with the try it out.
They did. So it's based
on this guy who, you know,
he made a video about how he wanted to
get fucked by black guys and he was like,
you can move in for free. You can switch
accounts, you can live it for free,
free rent, free food, free rent. You
could piss on me, beat me, try it out.
And he's like, try it out
guy. He always, he just says,
you know, try it out. So
people make their different versions
of the try it out, guy for us.
I love try it out.
Be Cool about it.
Listening.
It's a cow with a mustache.
Calm.
It's free. Rent. You guilty. So the key,
fuck me piss on you. Basically a home.
I know. He's seen me where I come over
today to try it out, man. My bills.
I like when dogs and cats do people
hostage.
Try it out by Rick.
Black guys love to fuck and fuck.
Good Bureau, hot black
guy. You want to fuck me?
Uh, 23 and that you want to
move, then you can move in.
So this is
very creative. Take on. Yeah, they're
all very crazy. A lot of times, you know,
we have people doing it,
jogging. We had women do it.
We had a woman do it in a seductive
way. We've had uh, aggressive,
we felt like Shakespearean.
Yeah. We had the uh, kind of, um,
like the law and order scene where the
guy had like a whiskey with him and he
was like, you know, try it out man.
So here's a polite, try it out.
I have something prepared here.
Gentlemen,
Enjoy Hobo, erotic sex, and have
had extensive experience in sex.
If you're African American who
has made healthy life choices?
What do I enjoy an afternoon with me?
I currently reside at 2195
do you need a place to stay?
I can accommodate what you
must engage me sexually.
I have a rare medical condition that
does require me to have sexual relations
often and in return I shall supply you
with food and shelter and anything else
you may need to survive.
He's a fucking lads,
plantation owner,
penal system,
southern gentleman residences or from
a more radical different upbringing.
My doors are always open
to you and your mates,
your name and all the proper
paperwork and I do have an extra key.
I do grant you permission
to urinate on me.
It's pretty good, man. That's,
that's pretty good. I enjoyed it.
Who is that guy? Did he get
what he wanted? I bet he
did. I don't know that the,
the guy actually got you ever see the
guy looking for a girlfriend? Yes,
I'm looking for,
I'm looking for guilt.
They had those posts all over New
York with looking for a girlfriend.
Just want someone to be,
until I talk about books and movies with,
if you're into that,
I'm looking for,
I look for the kill so you can
just have like a flyer and be like,
I'm leaving her girlfriend.
The guy's kind of ugly though,
and it's almost like
putting the focus on like,
do you know if she wants something
real, I'm here for you. But it's like,
I see that,
but yeah,
it's fucking weird as fuck what's
happening to your body. Hey, no,
it was crazy.
What the fuck is,
are you blowing up like a goddamn balloon
right now? You've got a thing inside.
You're kicking against you. I know.
Like alien. It's bananas. It's nuts.
It's a person. Can you feel it as
done? A kick and a punch? Yeah.
It kicks your ribs. He
stretches out. What does flips?
He flips around and say, fuck
on this podcast. Yeah. Oh yeah.
How much do you want to be to kill
these people? Nope. Cool. Hang on.
No water scapes. Just a such
a serene, tranquil setting.
Shut up page.
Doring.
Yeah. Would you go to Romania? I would
go. What'd you participate? Yeah,
just a little bit. You put on the mermaid.
I mean, I wouldn't give up spots for it,
but it was a daytime thing and a city I'm
in and I start our radio day. Yeah. Oh,
maybe you'd go,
that's a little bit
borough North Carolina.
Are you still live there?
I mean it's from all over the world here.
This is the largest,
he lives in Greensboro.
Yeah. So fourth grade. Huh?
First herb meetup ever
Marie meetup as global.
Cause they got one,
one lady from Afghanistan I this
harmless. Yeah. You think so?
One of us.
I mean,
except for the extensive
abuse that what if that would,
if they were abusing them,
like the fucking Michigan State guy was
somebody to meet me up at this beautiful,
nice thing and it's
like, oh no, it's ruined.
I've made these tails right here. They
make their own trails. Don't tell anybody.
They take me over four months.
My Tales of our range from 2,902
her gown tail and it gets swimming.
Wow. You think it's hurting anybody?
Oh No, he is hurting anybody.
I mean, I think it's, it's beyond
absurd. I wouldn't see that walk.
I don't want to see them like
they're like, ah, oh yeah, sure.
I could walk in this thing that's
been taught by grand for it.
I mean it's for children, the children
for children, but a good, that's an adult
weighs 50 pounds, 50th neutrally
buoyant. That's important.
What do you mean?
How many fuck ups do you think happened
during the day while they're deciding to
do? It's like, oh right. It was 90
pounds. We did lose a few people. Yeah.
When people were drying up,
we didn't pay her last merger mania.
We lost a few of our fellow Mermaids,
but what did they do?
They just put on there nice couture gowns
and then swim around with each other
and then look at each other
and that's the whole point.
But he's just a convention pool,
like a bunch of fucking nerds in a pool.
That's what it is.
Four years ago I discovered that there
was other word bracelets. People bad.
We're in love with Mermaids
as I was as easy as the girls.
You see a mermaid, like everybody's
like, oh, how beautiful.
But you see a guy and there
they're kind of, yeah,
of course. Yeah. Yeah.
But also like how often
are you seeing people see mermaids
where you're making this decision? Yeah.
It doesn't happen all the time. Yeah. I
feel like your data points are not enough.
This guy,
he really,
I mean the crazy thing is you get this
level of heterosexuality in the Merman
industry. It's very weird. I still don't
know how people have time for this shit.
That's always a thing. As an adult, you
don't have a fucking job. A mortgage.
Kids like I have the answers
for your mermaid. Yeah.
Where are you making time for these
kind of hot Megan Megan Tales for four
months.
I mean even for him to go down to the
pool with the fucking crown and they make
on and you've got to rent out
the whole pool or can you,
this seems like a giant pool and
you get half and half with my kids.
I don't know. Seems like other
like serious swimmers Beck.
You guys got to get the fuck
out. It's five o'clock now.
Get Out. We're doing laps.
Yeah. Take your, your come fins
Outta here so I can work out.
Yeah. Yeah. This is just a
different version of wild,
wild west. Get them out of,
he's clearly, he's straight, so I think,
yeah. Well do you think he's there?
He's in it for the girls. The in which
case that's a good bracket. It's a good,
how are you going to get
laid when everyone's wearing
a fucking tail over your
vagina? Yeah. It's not, it's not thought
out. It just comes when they're like,
when it's time to like, hey, let's, let's
go look at our tails together in my room.
It's a flop around like
wherever the water,
other Merman
have the world talk to
share the love of the seat
in it and a bunch of dams.
Yeah. I'll have to do is it, don't
like kids doing this. That's cool.
When I first started
doing this mermaid thing,
there was no one else in the world
that was doing it as a freelance job.
And it is a child to look around
and see that there's hundreds,
thousands of roommates around the world.
How do you know that I'm living? I agree.
How would you know what no one
else is doing it? Freelance.
We have something super
positive to awesome.
That would be so disappointing
about like meeting her.
There's no fat mermaid.
She's a murderer.
Met this girl at a bar or something
and you have no idea. Yeah. You like,
she's cute. Oh that's articulate.
Yeah. And then she's like,
I got this thing this weekend. I don't
know if you want to come check it out.
And you're like, yeah, what is what?
I'm interested in your interests.
I'm a mermaid. And then like all yours,
you're a fucking red flags. Kinda going
like fuck you.
I'll be like all your fucking hat.
I have a male ready to go out and
it just flags up flags up. This is,
this isn't going to go anywhere.
This thing.
Well and also she claims to be the
world's first freelance mermaid. But yeah.
How does she know that?
Well, because before this,
it was only people who
did it for a living.
They got four one ks and no one was
able to really shift this around a time
where you up time, all
freelance. She's a freelancer.
Thousands of roommates
around the world now.
Hundreds of thousands.
I don't know.
No living from doing this
beautiful art form art
form. I mean, Pete, how does she know?
She's the first machine still
drown at every convention,
but every week it better.
Yeah. There's a big one
there. Big Old Merc.
Wow.
Back to the birthplace of all life itself,
which is the Ocean Mermaid accent.
Well, no, but wait,
we need this to reconnect
with water. You know,
you can just go ahead.
It also doesn't give you
breathing ability. So scuba
diving is nice as well. Uh,
snorkeling, swimming. I just
want to say you're both jerks.
That's a nice thing.
People were getting together for
a nice time and you guys were just
were just bullies. Yeah. You're
just, you're just terrible.
Seems like it really,
I think what angers by five another Merman
is going through a 65 five another
merman. And the kid was like, Yo
you sorry your buddy. I knew you were
here. I didn't choose to say anything.
It just anchors me that it's adults like
grown people wasting their time with
this horse shit.
Do you think it's the same as a
kickball league or dodge balls?
35 year olds.
Yeah.
So you know,
uh,
bangs on,
it's like stop it gross.
Last week we had a
banks
grow the fuck up because anymore you're
not 12 stop it and quit wearing onesies
idiot women pajamas. Get the fuck
over yourselves. We're adult clothes.
Take you 45 minutes to Piss
stop it or non functional.
You know we had a Fart Simpson.
Tony do that prank call and
amazing prank call aware.
He used that, try it out guy
and played it for people. No,
he had a guy,
he put an ad in,
he went elaborate had the guy had
an ad out for renting his home.
So then a guy was like,
I'm interested in renting this place.
And then he answered the
phone and was like, Oh,
talk to my dad or my uncle was his place.
And then use the soundboard to be the
piss on me, beat me guy. Like, um,
and they got talked to
him. It was amazing. It was
amazing. And it was, I mean,
it was amazingly, and the guy was like,
I wouldn't, yeah, I want to come in July.
And then the board would be like,
you want to move in? You can move in.
And he's like, yeah, I want to come in
food
free rent at guys like free rent. And he's
like, fuck me, piss on me. I was like,
wait, what? It was fantastic. Played
it perfectly time. It's perfect.
Wow. He did another one
where he called, um,
this Texas rapper that he
found on craigslist. Um,
he's been calling him as different
members of will Smith's family. And uh,
and this time he got,
he got this kid to talk to
a soundboard of Jaden Smith,
will Smith's son. I mean, the kid talks to
him,
what's pop? And this,
my name is Jaden Smith.
You seen La la land in
Minlow Anda and man. Yeah,
like base my life mostly off of La la
land. I've never seen that movie though.
If that's a movie, it's an ammonia.
Yeah. Who live in my life level.
They Will Smith's son.
Yeah.
So I guess you know I rap correct.
Last verse was before the Award Show,
I contacted on my torso.
I don't have icon tatted on my torso.
Do you know what I'm saying? I
know what you're saying. Damn.
Um, yeah. Being obsessed
with like the sunset,
the sunset and I'm like so obsessed
with it. I'm in the Sun, Sarah. No.
Are you watching me or something that
somehow this is very strange as some say.
It is nice though. I agree. It's
just a random guy. It's a random guy,
I guess has put that he's
a rapper. Oh yeah. Online.
And I know it's so how
disconnected are you?
Just a mice drawer at the fucking keys
to compelling knowing what things to say.
Oh, I think he's prepped for every cause.
You're not just playing and pausing.
You're like deciding what to play
well in the moment. The future. Yeah.
I believe you, you know, but my vision is
for people to listen to the inefficient.
What do you mean? What
do you think? Joe Smith,
Jimi Hendrix lighting guitars on fire.
It's like, wow. Like no one does.
No one does this. Oh, like bat
like that inner vision. Yeah. Yeah.
Bedroom in his bad ass,
man. That's just shit son.
You should go for it every
time he three brother.
I don't got to tell him to put you
on a stretcher stretcher. I am here.
Anna still flex and flex and I am just
an icon living start a record label.
Ms Fish just did it while I'm high
snob cover five minutes. Whoa.
We are too hot in the business world.
You just make that up. Yeah, you did.
Didn't she hit? Yeah, you just
made pretty incredible man.
You can make freestyle music then. Thank
you. You should do it, man. Just tell him,
tell him the streets down.
There'll be like holy shit.
Much respect because
they're very respectful.
That shit in that what's your spitting
is nice, Bro. What's at this point?
This guy's having like a fucking five
minutes. What is this? What is this?
I don't know. So necklace in mind. It's
like he's just talking to a sound bar.
You know? It's so crazy, but I think
this guy might be a little crazy.
The guy that he called. Yeah, definitely.
Yeah. I think something's wrong with him.
Yeah, it's sick like Xanax. Let's take
as in they smoking out, chill out,
then get blunt.
He's trying to be hell cause the blood
comes after the yell cause the hours in
why? That's the way it goes. The sake
of the EC has spoken blood. Whoa.
People hit me on Twitter like [inaudible]
let me talk my piece on and they hit
me on the gram like Jay, you styling.
You know my swag was on a thousand.
Hello, is this you guys do
send me a picture of it.
Wait, what? Forget it.
It's so embarrassing to hear people rap.
Isn't it like freestyle? Absolutely.
I can't think of what's more embarrassing.
Somebody singing with an acoustic
guitar at me or somebody rapping to me.
I feel like they're both part
three of the somebody rapping
at you. Yeah. So it sounds like you want
to hear me spit and you're like, okay.
And then they asked. Yes. I would
love to hear your spit. Yeah.
And then there they actually go for it.
Uh,
everything inside of me would
tense up for sure. Two. Pardon me?
Thinks any musician is
super lame because like,
so what do you have like a singing
club with your friends? Yeah.
Like when you break it down to that level
of like if we were in high school and
you're just like, hey, we're all going
to sing together, play some music.
John would play the piano and
I'll sing. It's true. That's a,
we have a joke telling club,
I guess. Yeah, that's true.
We don't all meet together and do it.
We do it on stage alone. That's true.
But it is weird, right? It is
joke. Yeah. It's weird. But
how weird is it? Someone's,
uh, when somebody's like, hey,
you want to hear my new bit? Oh,
I don't like that either. They tried to
do it to you. I got to. Who does that do?
What the fuck is this? Do you guys send
me a picture of this in front of boobs?
No. Are you talking about, I
don't know, cause he took drugs.
Somebody with just like a picture of
boobs with like this type of Medallia. No,
sweetie, we don't right now. No.
Two days ago. No, not lost on,
no, he thought that. Okay.
Tom Sending you titty pics. You
want more of this guy or no? Yeah.
All right.
Well do you want me to throw it? I will
blow up. You want me to throw? No, no,
please. I'm an icon. Yes,
you are an icon. Holy Shit.
This is crazy. All right. It's
reality hasn't really hit me. Okay.
I'm trying to clear people's palettes.
This is bad ass man. What do I do?
What do I do to make my, make my music be
heard by the masses, man. Somebody will,
Smith's son Tommy went to do,
you can sit and like whatever way
you want to say it or imagery.
What's going on here?
Yeah, and it just keeps
going on. Parasites. It is.
He really embarrassed or just things to
be said in some of the things that I say
are super important.
I wouldn't talk when I was young
because I was contemplating life weird,
you know? I mean this guy just as
full hook line and pull in. Yeah.
He's all eight on this asking
for advice saying crazy shit.
But I think,
I think he's pretty fucked up.
Just thinking about Jada
Pinkett Smith the other day,
I remember when her children
were younger and she was,
they were starting to push them
into show business and she was like,
they were doing show business shit
really loud 10 yeah. And she's like,
there is so much talent in our house.
We are so talented like, and I just
think now that I'm a parent and I'm like,
I couldn't even imagine the
pimping my children at all. Never.
I would never pimp out my, you know what
I mean? Yeah. It's handy or all 11 year.
They're too young. It's too, it's too,
if your child actor best case scenario,
case scenario,
best case scenario, they book
nothing. Right. They just,
and then they're met with like their
parents disappointment cause they're not
doing well. Right. That's best
case scenario. Worst case scenario,
they book a bunch of stuff,
become child celebrities and have
an Odi at 26 that's like crazy.
It was pretty bad. Said, why
would you make your kid, I
don't know. It's terrible.
It's terrible.
I so talented.
There's so much talent in this house too.
Celebratory.
When they asked her about literally are,
they're fucking silly.
People asked her about like
if they have an open marriage,
we all can do what he wants to do.
If he can look at himself in the mirror.
Oh, and everybody was like,
wait, what does that mean?
That means that means that some
shit don't fuck anybody ugly.
Basically. You could look himself in
the mirror, like whatever, I guess. Wow.
Oh my gosh,
that's crazy.
How do you put reins on will Smith?
I mean, he's like the hottest dude.
You know guys like that.
They just fuck.
This family's too talented
to be held back sexually.
Trying to think of can you,
what if,
what if we were one of your kids wanted
to go into acting? What would you do?
I say, wait until you're 18 at least
to your same as same as alcohol.
Same as what? Same alcohol. Like not
now. These are adult things, things.
I don't think you're emotionally equipped
for the judgment and the criticism and
especially now. I mean, my goodness,
he put something up on Youtube,
people shit on you. It's like, Gosh,
why would you want that to like,
no, I'm not interested. I
don't even, he doesn't need
to work. You know what I mean?
Fine. You can just be cured job later.
Get a summer job and that's it. Yeah.
I wouldn't put the kid to work, man.
Let's work. It's show business, you know?
Terrible. Yeah. No.
What kind of mom or Dad to knowing
now what you know who would do that?
I think they're living through the city.
This fucking city where I know,
I think you think it's glamorous and fun
and like a hobby or something like that
kid don't know. There's like,
Whoa, let them in a school play.
We'll get just as much out of
it. Yeah, maybe that I'd be like,
do your school stuff. Yeah. All
right. See if you like it there. Um,
all right. Where can people
see you coming up? Um,
I'll be the Edinburgh cost comedy
festival. No, that's right.
August 2nd through the 26.
What's the show called?
Just called Ju Ju Ju.
Um,
uh, I think I could have a
storytelling show here in la,
but that I'm in the middle of July,
but mostly it's that,
and then I go and do a European tour
in November. It's stuff that's fun.
Where are you going? Do you know? Yeah.
All over Brussels, Belgium. Berlin.
I'm going to finally for the first
time you've been there. I Love Berlin.
So excited. It's such a cool
city. I got three days there.
What about Budapest? Any hunger
going in there and stuff? No. No.
I'd like to, you've been there
a? Yeah. What'd you go there? Oh,
my family's from there. Oh really?
Oh, cool. Yeah. Yeah, yeah man. Man,
they don't like joy that much now. I
think about it. They might not want jokes.
When are you due?
July 18th.
You got to make sure they're situated.
Then I could finally hit the road
for life and I'll see you later.
Can you and going on the road. I mean
I'm, I've been home for a couple of weeks.
I'm going to stay home through
most of August because of this kid,
because of this kid. Yeah.
That's cool. That's a fun one.
But then it's like peace.
Like for real.
How will you pay for a car a month
habit that you have? Uh, I don't know.
Trying to figure it out. I mean, you're
not gonna start getting a used car market.
That's gross. Don't even say that.
Um, uh, that you're going to hard. Yeah.
Well No, it's not too crazy actually.
Just not too crazy. It's
two weekends a month through
November. Oh, okay. So again,
we're, we're good. Let's wrap it
up. Let's wrap it up. Wrap it up.
I have a podcast called arch verse
skeptic tank. Eh, I dunno. Um,
I saw the opening for the, um, the
degenerates. Oh Yeah, look, look,
cool as fuck.
Cause I'm friends with Thomas fucking so
the Tamasic cause I want to say Tom six
new movie. A tag tag. How is it I want to
this super fun. I really want to go see.
Yeah. Um, yeah, it's
Super Fun. It's great. Um,
what was I going to say?
But yeah,
the opening for the generates
that he made looks fucking
good cause it was hard as fuck to shoot.
Oh, while you have that pregnant belly,
it was so hot to look cool. The call. I,
I hope it, yeah, I'm excited to see it.
Uh,
don't forget that new episodes are,
are going to be streaming
two hours before youtube. Uh,
now it's twitched on the
patriarch a twitch, twitch,
twitch.tv/your mom's house podcast.
Uh,
so you can go there and chat it up.
Uh, your queen genes one, right?
Queen genes one. Yeah. You guys have
a message board on twitch? On twitch.
It's my identity on twitch is queen
gene's number one and I am a Dj dad mouth
one. So, uh, we'll be
jumping on then there. Maybe.
Can I do tomorrow?
I don't know if I can do tomorrow or not,
but I'm going to be there as
often as I can, so that's that.
Cool. All right. Your catch him
Edinburgh catch 'em all over.
Listen to his podcast.
Thanks for coming on your name right.
What do you name your kid Perry
area. Okay. I'm okay with,
that's all right. We'll talk
to you later. Bye. Love you.
All right.
You don't say
same,
right?
You know what I'm saying?
Mom. Mom, mom.
That same French soon us.
You know what I'm saying?
Some there of know what I'm saying?
The mayor, you know what I'm saying?
Please.
You don't it.
Oh,
la La.
Right.
Okay.
How about
do you get a one on this fence?